What supplements do you recommend to get rid of glyphosate in your body?
There was a product out there that worked marketing I believe, but I don't remember the name of it. So
There isn't anything specific that will get rid of
you know glyphosate or mercury toxicity or
lead poisoning or
micotoxins. It is you're having to use key later,
keylation products and you're using products to get rid of this stuff that's already in the cell that will
uptake or uptick the production of glutathione. So remember glutathione is your main interest cellular
antioxidant and glutathione is made in the in the mitochondria of your cells and glutathione will
help get rid of toxins out of the cell but then using keylators will help grab onto them and bring
them through the blood out of the tissues and into your liver. So that's really what you're looking
for now. We've talked many times about the pros and cons of using something that will increase
glutathione with a cancer patient. So because many of the cancer therapies, especially from a medical
standpoint, are therapies that are stimulating reactive oxygen and species. So you're using glutathione,
you have the possibility of keeping a cancer alive because the cancer cells are much more susceptible to
in death by reactive oxygen and species than a healthy cell is. So I would stick to the key later
type things and so Chris you're already taking I think I remember correctly already taking a bunch
of stuff from cell core. A lot of the cell core products are exactly what we're talking about. So
cell core products, they have the human effulvic acid, they have, you know,
depending on what product it is, it might have charcoal, it may have, you know, different types of
keylators. Now there are some other just your general type of keylators which are EDTA and DMSA.
Those are general keylators that have been shown statistically and research wise to work great for
heavy metals and such. And then there's the ones in cell core that are just more general keylators and
BIPERS.